PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Deconstructing Chatbots.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode,
we will learn how to
create an App Engine front
end for our Dialogflow agent.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, so far in
the series, we've
been focusing on learning the
basics of conversational AI
and building an agent.
Once the agent is
built, you may want
to integrate it with the
front end of your choice
to give it a look and
feel of your own website.
Well today, we will learn
to create a custom front
end for our Dialogflow
chat application
on App Engine using
the Django framework.
You can use any front-end
framework or language you like.
Django is just an example
we are working with here.
But before we begin, here
is what we are building.
There'll be a text input
and a Submit button
to send chat messages.
All the messages
back and forth will
be visible on the chat window.
All right.
So let's see how this will work.
The chat app will be
served on App Engine.
We will build our
app in Python using
Django, which is a Python-based
free and open source web
framework.
App Engine will interact with
Cloud SQL for any database
requests.
And it will interact
with our Dialogflow
agent via the Dialogflow API.
In this example, we'll be using
the appointment scheduler agent
that we created in
the third episode.
And we enhanced it
in the eighth episode
to integrate with
Google Calendar.
Now with that background,
let's dive in and
see how to make this work.
Check out the link in
the description below
to download the
source code for Django
app we will be
deploying on App Engine.
Let's start by
creating the Cloud SQL
instance in GCP console.
Once created, take note
of the connection name.
Also create the database
with username and password.
If you don't already
have the Cloud SQL proxy,
then download and install it.
You'll find the link in
the description below.
Start the Cloud SQL
proxy with the connection
name we copied while creating
the Cloud SQL instance.
This establishes a connection
from your local computer
to your Cloud SQL instance
for local testing purposes.
Keep the Cloud SQL proxy
running the entire time
you test your app locally.
While we are in GCP console,
let's download the service
account key as well.
From the hamburger menu,
navigate to the API & Services.
Click on Create Credentials
button dropdown.
Then select the
Service Account Key.
Name the key and make
sure JSON is selected.
Then click Create.
The JSON file will then
download on your computer.
Open settings.py
in MySite folder.
In two places, replace your
user name and your password
with the database username
and password you just created.
This helps set up the
connection to the database
for both App Engine
deployments and local testing.
Also replace Cloud SQL your
connection name corresponding
to the host.
Replace your database with the
name of the Cloud SQL database
you created.
When done, close and
save settings.py.
Now let's set up the Dialogflow
detect intent endpoint
to be called from
the application.
For that, navigate to views.py
file in the Chat folder
and change the Google project
ID to your GCP project ID.
Appointmentscheduler.json
file is
used to authenticate and
authorize the app to make calls
to the Dialogflow API.
You replace that file with
your own JSON credentials
that we generated earlier.
To run the Django app
on your local computer,
we will need to set up a
Python development environment.
CD into the project directory.
Run the command
virtualenv env -p python3
to create the
virtual environment.
Now execute source
env/bin/activate
to activate the virtual
environment we just created.
You will see env
in the terminal,
which indicates that you are
in the virtual environment.
Now execute pip install
-r requirements.txt.
This will install
the requirements
for Django, Dialogflow,
and PI MySQL.
Then run the three migration
commands to set up the models.
Python3 manage.py
makemigrations,
makemigration
polls, and migrate.
At this point, we are ready
to start the local web server.
For that, execute python3
manage.py runserver.
Once the server is running,
navigate to localhost
on 8,000/chat.
And there, we have our
app running locally.
Now we are ready to deploy
our app to App Engine.
For that, we need to
gather all our static files
in one folder using the
command python3 manage.py
collectstatic.
Then run gcloud app deploy
to deploy the application
on App Engine.
This may take a few
minutes, but once done, you
will see the link to
the deployed application
in your terminal.
Navigate to the app and verify
that everything's working fine.
Today, we learned how
to create and deploy
a Dialogflow front
end on App Engine
using the Django framework.
I'm excited to hear which
front ends you are integrating
Dialogflow with.
Tell us all about your use
case in the comments below.
I hope to see you in the next
episode of Deconstructing
Chatbots.
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]